29 juillet c'est le jour du dépassement
mondiale enfin ça c'était en 2010 mais
le jour à partir duquel nous auront
consommé l'intégralité des ressources
renouvelables que la planète fournie en
une année c'est le bien cette année ce
jour du dépassement il surviendra trois
semaines plus tard un effet collatéral
positive du cornât virus même si c'est
une date symbolique elle nous renseigne
sur le niveau d'exploitation de la terre
agriculture transports hydrocarbures les
principaux contributeurs de la pollution
atmosphérique et est sur pause pendant
presque trois mois
ça s'est ressenti et ça se voyait même à
l'oeil nu
exemple ici avec la grande muraille de
chine
ou encore cet édifice de pékin on devine
à peine
en temps normal le voici en temps de
pandémie
les concentrations de polluants dans
l'atmosphère ont chuté que ce soit le
dioxyde d'azoté qu'on voit ici où le
plus connu le dioxyde de carbone - 24 %
pour la chine jusqu'à -30 4% en france
et à l'échelle mondiale ses 17 % de
diminution
problème selon ce directeur à l'agencé
spatiale européenne il ya le risque
d'intensifier les émissions si la
reprise de l'activité est brutale mais
surtout l'effet de cette diminution sera
marginal compte tenu des millions de
tonnes de particules déjà présentes
le speech in a way son conseil que les
plans de relance place vraiment
l'environnement au coeur de la réflexion
car si le fameux retour à la normale
ressemble à ça la concentration de
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
restera à des niveaux inégalés dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
comme c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
selon les nouvelles données de
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal